Frances there's an Englishman waiting
for you these tables are no good no good
at all he is from the Hudson Bay Company
he gave lafarge exact measurements a
table it was not tilt or Lister that is
all right ask for a property but this
people deal with the table at the proper
time there is a man he is wonderful you
have ruined my refined how it would be -
we don't have money for these reference
status it is the floor that is tilt not
the table I advised against green wood
planks but did you eat my advice No
everything here is poor and broken and
made wrong even this is no you solve
these are unrefined tables deserve
unrefined food for unrefined men that is
our business Francis a minute is a
minute are not five my apology is my
husband and I we were just discussing
refinements well after our room I too
actually
he is my equal and will be treated as
such I had the other guest to consider I
wish to be civil in all enterprises but
I will not be denied a proper room for
my co-equal even though he can't speak
for himself I use deadly with that book
I am NOT as equal on that my apologies
we were ready to Rooms Thank You Matteo
Geetha
i'ma told I wish to know about her
recent guest in your in my husband keeps
very careful reverence of all the guests
well then I'm looking for a mr. rondell
cross he was not familiar to me he was
an agent for the Hudson Bay Company his
correspondence indicate that he was a
guest at your in he describes the food
is adequate no he did have a few words
of praise for the prune tart exceptional
you wrote it can be here on occasion we
would like to see the room mr. Kraus
stated first I must check to see if he
was a guest this I mr. cross was a guest
he stayed in the Rose suite he left us
some time ago I just want to make sure
before I am sure his men do not have
time for games Frances
[Music]
you